people have a general idea of insanity
or craziness or madness that they
associate with the idea of schizophrenia
it's kind of an idea of wildness not so
much what psychosis might actually be
but more of an idea of violence or just
being crazy
my name is Asma Wagin Wang I attended
Yale University and Stanford University
and I have been diagnosed with
schizoaffective disorder bipolar type
since 2013 before I was diagnosed with
schizoaffective disorder I had already
been in the mental healthcare system for
quite a number of years I had been
diagnosed with depression and anxiety
since I was about 15 or 16 and then I
was diagnosed with bipolar disorder in
my late teens when I was finally
diagnosed with schizoaffective disorder
I felt a great sense of relief it's
quite common for people to go through a
number of diagnoses before they reached
their final diagnosis and I think that
part of the reason this happens is that
it's get so affective disorder in
particular but also the schizophrenia is
in general is a rather stigmatized
diagnosis and so often doctors will
resist that diagnosis for as long as
possible so they start with the kind of
quote unquote easier diagnosis they
might start with depression and then
move on to bipolar disorder as they did
in my case people tend to think of
schizophrenia in a way that they don't
think about other mental health
diagnoses when people think about
depression they often think about the
person that has depression as still
themselves when they think about
schizophrenia they tend to think about
this person who is who they were but
then kind of scooped out and removed and
replaced by this awful disease and the
person who used to be there and was a
good and normal person is gone they're
possessed as though by a demon as though
in the movie The Exorcist except instead
of a demon they're replaced by
schizophrenia because people think that
there is a kind of possession involved
in schizophrenia or the schizophrenia is
they also believe that the person has no
autonomy over themselves and no right to
make decisions over their own care
therefore forcible treatment or forced
hospitalization becomes necessary
I think that in order for schizophrenia
and the schizophrenia is to become less
taboo in culture there need to be more
stories I think that people need to come
out about their diagnosis there need to
be more narratives about what the
diagnosis means but there also needs to
be better treatment and if there's
better treatment if there are more
stories if there are more narratives if
people can know that there are people
all around them who have this diagnosis
I think stigma will decrease I use my
accomplishments I use the way I dress I
use my relationships all as ways to
prove look I'm still a worthy member of
society even though I have this severe
form of mental illness this also means
that I'm part of the problem when it
comes to looking at people who are
perhaps less quote-unquote
high-functioning the person on the bus
who's screaming the houseless person who
has lost their job because there is
something very wrong with them in terms
of their mental health and I know that
that is me dealing with the stigma as
well the self stigma that is their
diagnosis as well as mine I would like
people to understand that it's possible
for you to know somebody who has
schizophrenia or some form of the
schizophrenia is without you knowing
people with that diagnosis like me are
everywhere and we are living lives that
are full and wonderful and we also like
blueberry pie
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon